uh
[Music]
good
well hello dear friends welcome to our
program
i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
where
those who watch
our television programs send their
questions to us
we do the research and then to the best
of our ability and by god's guidance
we seek to answer the questions that you
send us
let me give you the electronic address
where you can send them to us you'll see
it on the screen it's tv
at some tv dot org
once again tv at some tv
dot org please send us your questions we
have many of them
sometimes it takes us a while to get to
all of them but be patient keep tuning
in and eventually we will get to the
point where we will answer your question
i have with me pastor daniel miranda who
is an associate speaker here at secrets
unsealed
you know his official title is associate
speaker for
the latino pro
channel
but
he does a lot of things in english as
well
so
he's just we'll just call him the
associate speaker of secrets unsealed
and
i would like to ask him to have a word
of prayer to start our program and then
we'll go right into our questions thank
you let's pray
dear heavenly father as we
seek your guidance to answer these
questions we pray for
the enlightenment of the holy spirit
we pray lord that you may help us stick
to your word that we may not say
something that is not there and that
these answers may
help those who have
asked these questions we pray all these
things in the name of jesus amen amen
okay this question has to do with
divorce
so i'm going to read the entire message
and then
pastor miranda is going to be sharing
some thoughts with us
this is what this person wrote
i probably should not mention the name
because of more of a personal nature
correct um i greet you all at secrets
unsealed in the blessed name of jesus
christ our lord and soon coming king
i have a personal question prayer
request and biblical counsel to ask of
you
i am on the verge of a divorce
which is being hastily and persistently
urged by my wife
in all the private conversations we have
had together
after she brought this matter to the
table
i have prayerfully and politely sought
to stem the tide of her request
but she consistently made it known to me
that she doesn't love me anymore
i still love my wife dearly
and have no intentions to separate with
her
let alone remarry anyone else should
this painful process go through as she
desires
is it wrong here comes the question is
it wrong for me to respect and value her
liberty of conscience in this matter
and sign the bill of divorce
secondly
would god's name be honored if in my
choice to remain single
while i patiently and prayerfully make
attempts to win her affections again
and for god to restore our union as he
did for hosea in bible times
our families will be having a meeting
this coming weekend therefore i kindly
ask that you pray for god's intervention
regarding my marriage
this was sent to us
some time ago a couple of weeks ago
so
you know we we since since we looked at
the questions because we take them in
order uh we've been praying for this
person who is writing to us
uh the
email ends by saying any consoles via
audio or video tape sermons i can listen
to and books i can read that you
recommend that will help me at this time
will be much appreciated so
what would we recommend to this person
whose wife
is determined she doesn't love her
husband anymore she wants a divorce
but he wants the marriage to work
do we have any bible counsel on that
well first of all i think um
we do not know all the details about the
situation here with the brother it is
very sad and it really hurts me when i
hear that she doesn't love him anymore
but he still loves her that must be very
painful
now
the reason why she doesn't love him
anymore
we do not know so the first thing i
would say is
if there is something that you have done
that have
has led your wife not to love you
anymore
you should prayerfully bring that to the
lord
and make the right corrections
if you want to win
the love of your wife back
but
as you said here if the question is
is it wrong for me to respect and value
her liberty of conscience no it is not
wrong because she has
the liberty
to
separate you to divorce you and it
wouldn't be wrong if you sign the bill
of divorce
if she is requesting it not because you
want to divorce but you also have to
respect her decision although it is
painful and it is not your preference
that it is not god's will
now there is a bible text in first
corinthians chapter 7
where we find some a principle it is not
exactly the same case that you are going
through
but we have a
principle here on couples that are
unequally yoked that is one believes the
other doesn't believe
in first corinthians chapter 7 verse 10
and 11 we read now to the merit i
command yet not i but lord a wife is not
to depart from her husband
but if she does the part and it's
interesting that speaking about the wife
if she does the part let her remain
unmerit or be reconciled to her husband
and a husband is not to divorce his wife
now verse 15 if the unbeliever departs
let him depart
a brother or a sister is not under
bondage in such cases
but god has called us to peace so god
has called us to peace that's his idea
but if one of the spouses wants to live
we are not to force the person to
continue with us
the the difficult thing here is that we
don't have all of the information like
you were mentioning we don't know if
this individual's wife
is a believer
or not
whether they are unequally yoked because
she is not a believer and he is a
believer which makes the matter a lot
more complicated
you know if she is a believer
and she simply you know doesn't want to
be married to her husband
i'm just speculating now maybe she has
other interests
it's different than if she's a
non-believer they got married and he's a
believer she's a non-believer so if we
had more information we probably could
provide a more
satisfactory answer correct yeah
so i would say that first of all
i see the person that rides the husband
he believes in god because he says he
has been praying
so first of all keep praying
search your heart
and see where you have erred and where
you have lost your wife's love
and
continue to work
to win her love back
if
that is possible
and
and yield to your wife's desire because
she cannot be with you against her will
it kind of makes you think of the
name that he mentions hosea hosea it's a
very very similar situation that he has
you know because hosea was
faithful to his wedding vows and his
wife was not
and so
you know it's a difficult situation
we certainly will continue to pray for
this individual that the lord will touch
his wife's heart amen that
if she's fallen out of love she will
fall in love again amen and uh meanwhile
it's a very difficult situation for him
so hopefully this will help
we don't have all of the information but
we certainly will continue praying for
this individual
now the next question that we have
and this one is not of a personal nature
so
i'll mention the name thomas gilco
interesting email address a vegan sda45
at gmail
[Laughter]
that's a good thing this person
evidently is a vegan yeah so anyway
this is what he wrote
i love watching your programs
i've had an idea for a long time that i
want to run by you
i've not shared it much
because i'm not as close to
and knowledgeable of the lord as you
guys
revelation 14 11
what if the smoke of their torment is
the smoke that god has cloaked himself
with
to protect us from his glory
i know
the temple was always full of smoke when
he was in it
he was also cloaked in smoke and leading
the hebrews through the wilderness in
moses time
i think of the smoke as rising up like a
curtain so that he is fully revealed and
we know that this will be torment
for
for those who have not allowed him to
change them what do you think i stand
ready to give up the idea
lol
very interesting question and i think is
is very lined up his reasoning i've
never
looked at it from that perspective
but
so the the verse here
in question is revelation 14 11 and
let's read it
revelation 14 verse 11 and this is the
third angel's message
the bible says on the smoke of their
torment
ascends forever and ever and they have
no rest day nor day or night who worship
the beast in his image
and whoever receives the mark of his
name so the first thing that we see here
it is that this is speaking not of the
smoke of god right this is speaking of
the smoke of their torment the wicked
so what is that smoke i know pastor boy
you have a
you've done
anka bible school and you have touched
this so maybe you can share
some of
your points with us
yeah the bottom line is that the glory
of god we many times misunderstand what
the glory of god is the bible says that
god is like a consuming fire
who are the ones that will be able to
live in the midst of the consuming fire
the righteous well isaiah 33 tells us
that it's the righteous
who will be able to live
in the everlasting burnings they
everlasting fire because through the
grace of god they've developed a
fireproof character we might say
and so
you know they will be able to
live in the presence of a holy god
and not be consumed
as far as the wicked are concerned it's
a different story
because the fire
that refines god's people
is the fire that consumes the sinners
because they become identified with sin
but i think the main point
just to answer the question is
that
this smoke that is mentioned of in
revelation 14 11 is not the smoke that
surrounds god's glory that hides god's
glory it's really the smoke that ascends
from the burning of the wicked of satan
and his angels and the wicked correct
in in the bible
symbols
don't always mean the same thing
you know you look for example at the
expression sons of god you know it can
refer to angels
as in the book of job it can refer to
uh the
children yeah
and it can refer to god's children
a lion can be a symbol of satan it can
be a symbol of
jesus it can be a symbol of babylon it
can be a symbol of
you know judah the son of jacob so
just because smoke is mentioned
in this verse doesn't mean that it means
the same thing as other verses where the
word smoke is used correct
now to support your point
the expression the smoke of their
torment
that expression actually
um
to clarify that
comes from an old testament account yes
the the destruction of sodom and
gomorrah
and in genesis 19 verse 28
and actually we don't see some sodom and
gomorrah burning today
but in in genesis chapter 19 verse 28 we
read
in reference to the burning and the
destruction of sodom and gomorrah
the bible says here in verse 28 that
then he looked that's abraham toward
sodom and gomorrah and toward all the
land of the plane and he saw and behold
the smoke of the land which went up like
the smoke
of a furnace
we have the expression there that is
that the book of revelation borrows from
this account
and when we compare that with what jude
7 and 2nd peter 2 6 say for example jude
7 says that the cities of sodom and
gomorrah were punished with everlasting
fire
but when you go to ii peter 2 6
it says that sodom and gomorrah were
reduced to ashes
right so
it is not an eternal fire that is
burning
until today but right it only burns
until it consumes what is burning right
and you know we can also connect um
isaiah 34 where revelation 14 11
actually comes from
much of the language
in isaiah 34 it's talking about the
destruction of edom
and let's read verse 9 it says
speaking about edom
its streams shall be turned into pitch
and its dust into brimstone
its land shall become burning pitch
it shall not be quenched night or day
its smoke
shall ascend forever although
we know that forever means as long as
there's anything to consume because
they're not burning today so it says it
shall not be quenched night or day its
smoke shall ascend forever
from generation to generation it shall
lie waste
no one shall pass through it forever and
ever so
when it says here that
in verse
9 its stream shall be turned into pitch
and its dust into brimstone its land
shall become a burning pitch
it shall not be quenched day or night
its smoke shall ascend forever
that means no one shall pass through it
forever and ever so it means it's going
to be burned up and it will remain
destroyed forever
very good
okay well i hope that that helps with
with this particular question
now we have another question this one is
uh extensive
uh i don't think i'm going to read the
entire question
but it has to do
with the authority of the writings of
ellen white
whether ellen white was a true prophet
or not
now we know
that there are many websites out there
whose primary purpose is to discredit
ellen white
as a prophet of god
and they use all kinds of different
arguments you know she was in it for the
money
and she was a plagiarist
and you know she contradicted herself
there's all kinds of
complaints about ellen white and there's
bunches of sites out there that their
main purpose is to discredit ellen white
because they feel like if they can
discredit ellen white they can discredit
the entire seventh-day adventist message
so
what what do we say
to people who
you know who re go to these websites
i've had adventists that go to the
websites and they contact me alarm they
say pastor you know they're saying this
about all white what can we say is it
true
so what can we do in this case so
you know
when it comes to judge someone's works
instead of going to a website or to an
external reference
go to what the person really wrote amen
so for example if someone wants to get
to know what you believe and what you
teach
they should not go to another external
site that comments on your sermons they
should go to you directly
so the best thing would be to go
directly to the writings of ellen g
white
and find
and experience by yourself if those
messages are really from god or not
compare them with the bible and and see
if there is some contradiction and then
why has some councils in regards to how
to
lead those who are new in the faith
to believe in the testimonies she says
of course that we should not force them
but that they should have
personal experience with the visions
that's what she recommends so today we
don't have her life so that they can
have a personal experience with the
visions that the lord has given her but
we have her writings and she has written
a lot she has many books periodicals
letters we have all that available for
free on internet
and i would say the best thing is to go
and
encourage this person
to read
the books of alienware especially those
that deal with the great controversy
issue like patriarchs and prophets
prophets and kings these are of ages
acts of the apostles in the great
controversy also steps to christ christ
subject lessons
there is also a good book that we sell
here in our ministry
is written by dr herbert douglas
it's called the messenger of the lord
very good book that is a very good book
very solid balanced
where that presents very
um
wildly
the gift of prophecy and answer some of
these objections like plagiarism is she
plagiarized or not
if she was influenced by the people of
her time
if she got the health message from dr
jackson or not so he answers all those
things there in his book
yeah very good
you know
i wonder if you can show me one prophet
in the bible that the people liked
that's a
difficult i don't know of any prophet
that the people loved
and the main reason is because the
prophet
told things
like they are
the prophet does not embellish
everything you know the false prophets
they make people feel good and that's
why jesus said woe
to you
when men shall be well shall speak well
of you
because they did this with the prophets
and god takes personally
when a true prophet is attacked which
true prophets are always attacked in the
bible
jesus of course was a prophet he was
despised
israel stoned the prophets according to
jesus
in the old testament period
because the prophets told them what they
didn't want to hear
you know you look for example of the
story of elisha
who was who was a prophet the prophet
elisha
and you remember the 42 children that
were coming behind him and saying go up
thou bald head go up thou bald head god
took that personally they were being
critical
of
the prophet of god and illinois it
amplifies that the parents had taught
the children
to make fun of elijah yeah so it's very
it's very serious what parents tell
their children about the gift of
prophecy and then of course you have
moses the criticism of aaron and moses
and miriam against moses
you know god took it so personally
according to numbers 12
that the bible tells us that she
developed leprosy and it was only
because moses intervened and interceded
with god that she was healed from her
leprosy
and then you have the story of korah
nathan and abyram
who questioned the authority of moses
once again and we know what happened
the earth
opened up and swallowed them
so we have to be very careful
that we are not critical
of a true prophet of god amen and if
people are speaking many people are
speaking badly of the prophet
that's pretty enough pretty good
evidence that the prophet is a true
prophet correct
now pastor boy you recorded
some time ago a series on the gift of
prophecy yes here so that would be a
good resource that you can also
recommend to this person what's the name
of the series the name of the series is
believe is profits okay and it's 24
hours of material and
much of the material is unique
you know it's not just the same stuff
that has been said
all throughout the history of the church
it uh it has for example a parallel
between the book great controversy
and
the book of revelation very very
interesting parallels
there's also a parallel between john the
baptist as the lesser light
and the writings of ellen white being
the lesser light there's a striking
comparison there and
there there's many other things in that
series that that is unique it's not just
a repetition of what is in other books
and i would recommend
that everyone get a copy
of that dvd series and it also comes
with
one i think in one or two volumes i
think it's two volumes of resource
material uh dealing with that particular
topic very good very nice
um i would like to very briefly share my
testimony with with the experience of
the grit of prophecy
when i grew up in an adventist home but
i left the church for some time and when
i came back
i didn't want to believe just the things
that i used to believe because they had
been inculcated to me by my parents so i
decided to study all over again by
myself
and one of the greatest stumbling blocks
i had was the gift of prophecy because i
was prejudiced against prophets and the
reason is because when i was looking for
a church i went to a church where they
prophesy for you
and i remember one one night that was
evening that i went to this church and
there was a long line
and i was wondering like i asked what's
that line for and they said well the
prophet is here tonight
and
she's prophesying
and i was curious okay i'll make the
line and i like to hear prophecy from
the prophet
and the prophecy make the long story
short i was 17 years old i was looking
for a church i was in 11th grade
high school
so the prophet saw me and and she
started speaking in tongues and then she
put her hand on my head
and then she said you know you're going
to be very successful you're going to
study this at the university
and that caught my attention because i
was thinking of studying that
and i said wow she seems to be a good
prophet
and then she said
uh when you're in the second semester
you're going to marry someone that is
like this and you're going to have a lot
of money
so i was like doubting uh and i say is
that prophecy going to be true so when i
reached second semester of my career in
languages
i was waiting to see the fulfillment of
that prophecy
but that never happened and i was so
disappointed and discouraged with
prophets i was like 18 19 years old and
i say i'm not going to believe in
prophets but
when i heard that the seventh-day
adventist church has had a prophet i
said well i don't know if this is a true
prophet or not
and i went to the bible
compared the bible with the spirit of
prophecy started to read one book after
after the other
i think i have read
more than
30 books of lng white
and eventually i was convinced
that she is a true prophet of god i mean
what you find there is so
inspired so divine that is not human
wisdom and the transformation of her
writings in my character that is the
most powerful evidence
taste
and see that it is good don't go by what
other people say i found that there are
two types of people that are critical of
ellen white
one type of person
never reads her
that's one group that's one group yeah
but they know that she wasn't a true
prophet even though they've never read
her writings
the second group are individuals who
read her writings
with the purpose of criticizing
neither one of those groups are going to
be blessed by the writings of the spirit
of prophecy
you have to do with ellen white the same
thing that you do with the bible
and that is you come and you say
speak lord for your servant heareth
tell me
what you want me to know tell me what
you want me to do
no matter what the consequences i am
willing to do your will
it's kind of like samuel said speak lord
for your servant heareth
it's difficult to say that because we
don't want anything that will cramp our
lifestyle anything that is going to make
our life more difficult you know i'm
sure that when that prophet said those
things that you were going to be rich
and you were going to get married and
everything was going to go good you said
now that's got to be a true prophet
but when prophets say things we don't
want to hear
suddenly we turn the prophet off correct
but we need to be sincere
open heart open mind to receive what the
prophet says and then abide and live by
it amen
well folks our time is up for our
program today we trust that it was a
blessing to you
remember to send your questions to us at
tv
at
some tv.org
and may god bless you and we hope to see
you the next time on our program
i'd like to know
[Music]
you